lundi matin à la gare bélarus callas de
moscou les seuls qui ont droit de
circuler comme partout dans le pays sont
les travailleurs est essentielle et
c'est comme ça depuis le 31 mars
quant à moi ça devrait continuer jusqu'à
ce que la situation se stabilise dit là
où la coiffe
car malgré un confinement sévère est
presque total la russie enregistre
depuis une semaine plus de dix mille
nouveaux cas de covile par jour nous la
surprise générale d'entendre vladimir
poutine dans un discours à la nation
aujourd'hui annoncé qu'il lève pour de
bon l'interdiction travail et qu'il
avait ordonnées pour l'ensemble du pays
dès demain tous les secteurs de
l'économie seront le droit de redémarrer
dit il mais comment procéder à quel
rythme et avec quel protocole de
sécurité
cette histoire les conflits plutôt aux
gouverneurs des 80 5 régions du pays
la tâche de planifier la suite mais pour
nous les conséquences économiques du
confinement ont été pires que l'impact
sur la santé du scoop c'est l'idée de
calmer la grogne des travailleurs comme
natalia et son mari qui ont perdu leur
emploi en raison de la collègue 19
noeuds déconfinement même graduelle et
redouté par les médecins confrontés à la
réalité dans leurs hôpitaux d'urgence de
porter une robe monique up down et
boxster et jaune comme si tu relis
jamais rien vu d'aussi terrifiant de
toute ma vie dit le docteur une l'irak
manne de la région de vote les scènes
ski on enterre même nos propres collecte
beaucoup ont du mal à s'expliquer la
décision de la dîmière poutine alors
qu'en région doit encore convertir des
gymnases entier en centre de soins
intensifs pour une motion veut
s'afficher comme le grand libérateur
rouge
nuit en donnant le feu vert au
déconfinement dit l'analyste gleb
pavlovski
mais ce sont les gouverneurs paul lui
qui devront porter l'odieux de manière
des mesures sévères et est populaire
bien au delà du printemps ici tamara
intéresse qu radio canada mon frère